Isis terrorist Isis terrorists Isis
terrorists Isis or Islamic state is an
extremist Islamist militant organization
with complicated origins in dealing with
them is also complicated they want to
create the Caliph is based on an extreme
form of Sharia law and bring about the
apocalypse President Barack Obama
described dealing with them best it's a
Quogue one just who is Islamic state and
how did they form we put together a
timeline to answer these questions and
after watching it you should have a
better understanding of how we find
ourselves in this vlog one shortly after
the us-led invasion of Iraq in 2003 Abu
Bakr al-baghdadi who was born in Samarra
Iraq in 1971 and his real name is
Ibrahim Awad Ibrahim of bawdry
helps set up an insurgent group to fight
coalition troops in a year later in
February 2004 Baghdadi is arrested and
sent to the us-run Camp Bucca where he
meets former Baathist military
commanders and religious extremists Camp
Bucca has been described as a pressure
cooker for extremism and Baghdadi is
released after 10 months for good
behavior
but in 2006 he joins a group of Sunni
insurgents led by Al Qaeda and
specifically this guy Abu Musab
al-zarqawi
the group announces the formation of the
Islamic State of Iraq four years later
Baghdadi becomes the group's leader and
then a couple years after that they
announce a name change to the Islamic
state in Iraq and the Levant and becomes
known as ISIL or Isis - most of the
world and - in Arabic the group advances
westward from Iraq into war-torn Syria
and seizes oil wells to fund its war
chest a year later in January of 2014
Baghdadi's militants take full control
of the Syrian city of Raqqa which
becomes their de-facto capital
here they are making themselves at home
burning a large pile of cigarettes
led by Balthus commanders its fighters
move across northern Iraq as the Iraqi
army collapses capturing Mosul and other
cities to set up its territory on land
straddling the Iraqi Syrian border a
month later in February al-qaeda
formally ends its affiliation with the
group Jon Stewart says it best an al
Qaeda affiliate in Syria is so extreme
al Qaeda's like reports emerge detailing
Baghdadi's harsh from a rule executions
even among its own ranks become common
[Music]
up until this point there are only two
images of Baghdadi
but in June 2014 by Daddy reveals
himself and proclaims himself Calif a
successor to the Muslim Prophet Muhammad
selected by God and their group is now a
Caliphate an Islamic government ruled by
the Caliph he calls on Muslims to help
build an empire and the group changes
its name again shortening it to Islamic
state over the next month the u.s.
launches about a hundred and fifty
airstrikes against Islamic state
militants in Iraq in August 19 2014 in
retaliation british-born Islamic state
fighters mahmoud my z known as jihadi
john appears in a video beheading
American journalist James Foley a Newton
or Obama the group's slick propaganda
campaign aimed at inspiring both fear
and admiration is in full swing
a couple of weeks after that i'm brock
obama jihadi John beheads another us
hostage steven sotloff also on video and
then a few days after that
[Music]
my fellow Americans tonight I want to
speak to you about what the United
States will do with our friends and
allies to degrade and ultimately destroy
the terrorist group known as ISIL the
Obama administration announces the
formation of a coalition to bomb the
Islamic state it's a core principle of
my presidency if you threaten America
you will find no safe haven airstrikes
start across Syria on September 23rd
[Music]
more countries join the coalition
fighting the Islamic state in November
of 2014 an audiotape Baghdadi urges his
followers to erupt volcanoes of jihad
everywhere and his followers appear to
be listening the paris-based magazine
Charlie Hebdo has produced many
satirical covers over the years some of
them depict the Prophet Muhammad and
because of this On January 7th 2015 the
magazine headquarters was attacked
killing 12 people few days later two
gunmen kill four people at a kosher
grocery store al Qaeda and Yemen claims
responsibility for the magazine assault
but the militant who attacked the store
this guy appears in a posthumous video
declaring allegiance to Islamic state
signaling a cooperation between al Qaeda
and the Islamic state on a grassroots
level despite rifts between their
leaders
about a month later On February 3rd 2015
Islamic state broadcast video shows
lieutenant Mojave
Safi al-kasasbeh a Jordanian pilot being
burnt alive in a cage in a dramatically
shot sequence with touches of fake fire
like the wasn't covering the screen
right here the video shows the Islamic
state understands the manipulative power
of the imagery they send out to the news
and then a month after that militant
group Boko Haram pledges allegiance to
Baghdadi a couple weeks later Iraq
forces backed by us-led warplanes retake
Tikrit their first major battlefield
success but then about two months later
Ramadi capital of Iraq's Western Anbar
province falls to Islamic state
highlighting the ebb and flow of the war
not to mention this and all the other
fighting in this entire area has fueled
the biggest refugee crisis since World
War two and then on May 20th 2015
Islamic state captures Palmyra home to
Syrian Army installations they also
destroy the ancient monuments and fill
mass executions at the city's Roman
amphitheater
[Music]
month later and Tunisia the group claims
responsibility for the killing of 38
people at a beach resort that devastates
Tunisia is crucial tourism sector a
couple months later in September as
Islamic state seeks to profit from the
chaos in Yemen spiders carry out one of
the biggest suicide bombings in the
country and strike a Shiite mosque in
sana during Eid prayers killing 30
people then September 30th 2015
Russia enters the Syrian civil war to
back President Bashar al-assad against
rebel groups supported by Western powers
as well as the Islamic state a few weeks
later on October 11th two suicide
bombers fill more than 100 people in
Ankara Turkey the government blames
Islamic state for the worst attack of
its kind on Turkish soil and then on
October 31st 2015 a Russian passenger
jet crashes in the Sinai desert in Egypt
killing all 224 people on board in an
attack claimed by the Islamic states
affiliate in Egypt two weeks later
[Applause]
Islamic state claims twin bombs that
killed at least 44 people in its first
attack in Beirut Lebanon targeting a
stronghold of the militant Hezbollah
group that has been supporting Assad the
next day Kurdish forces driving LOM
exciters from the northern town of
Sinjar significant advance in a campaign
to regain territory seized by the
militant group the US says it's
reasonably certain it killed jihadi
john' and an airstrike remember this guy
unbuckle Baumol and then that very same
day
Islamic state fighters simultaneously
attack five locations in Paris killing
at least 130 people the French president
Francois Hollande calls it an act of war
as if elected to go and then France
starts bombing Islamic state strongholds
in Syria and retaliation the us-led
coalition against Islamic state dropped
a record number of bombs in November
doubling the amount they dropped in June
meanwhile in Libya Islamic state makes
gains and raises its black flags / cert
on the shores of the Mediterranean cert
becomes the first city Islamic state
governs outside of Syria and Iraq and
then back in the United States during a
holiday party at a facility that assists
individuals with developmental
disabilities two shooters a husband and
wife kill 14 people
evidence emerges that they strongly
support Islamic state and had become
self radicalized the two of them had
gone down the dark path of
radicalization embracing a perverted
interpretation of Islam that calls for
war against America and the West as the
internet erases the distance between
countries we see growing efforts by
terrorists to poison the minds of people
like the Boston Marathon bombers and the
San Bernardino killers in a radio
broadcast Isis praises the act despite
not having any contact with the couple
whatsoever and so this whole situation
continues to be a quagmire
you